wir haben über die vergangenheit
gesprochen wir haben über die gegenwart
gesprochen lassen sie uns über die
zukunft nachdenken die erste wichtige
frage über die zukunft ist natürlich
eine spekulative frage das ist völlig
klar es ist die frage wie wird dieser
krieg mutmaßlich enden
je früher und linie
eine eskalation die zu einem größeren
krieg führt mit der beteiligung der nato
und anderen halte ich nicht für
wahrscheinlich dieser krieg muss nicht
die atomare dimension erreichen ich habe
das gefühl dass beide seiten dieses
szenario vermeiden werden als der
konflikt noch dabei war sich zu
entwickeln sagte der amerikanische
präsident dass man nicht militärisch
intervenieren wird waffen ja soldaten
main und die atommächte wissen genau
dass es eine stufe der eskalation geben
kann in der die situation außer
kontrolle gerät
in der vorstellung der meisten ukraine
aber auch der europäer gibt es ein
zweites szenario nämlich eines das man
im russisch japanischen krieg zwischen
1905 und 1907 gesehen hat in diesen
trick hat man völlig vergessen
als ich student in bulgarien war in den
80er jahren war das einzige was wir
wussten die tatsache dass dieser krieg
zur ersten und dann zur zweiten
russischen revolution geführt hatte
aber wenn man die moral der damaligen
führer in den ländern der dritten welt
liest war das der wichtigste krieg
denn zum ersten mal hatte eine
nichtweiße nation ein weißes reich
dass die japaner gesiegt hatten war eine
große überraschung zu jener zeit und es
führte zu einer umfassenden die
stabilisierung in russland
viele glauben dass putin nicht an der
macht bleiben kann wenn er aus dem
ukraine krieg nicht als sieger
wie realistisch das ist kann man nicht
sagen
es hängt davon ab wie das volk darüber
denken würde und das einzige was ich
weiß ist dass niemand putin stürzen
würde wenn nicht eine mehrheit der
menschen meint dass er gescheitert sei
sogar für einen putsch im kreml braucht
man eine solche änderung der stimmung im
volk die frage die politik umtreibt ist
nicht warum er in die ukraine
einmarschiert ist sondern warum er nicht
gewinnt es geht um sein politisches
überleben
das dritte szenario ist ein
friedensvertrag und viele denken da an
das modell sowjetisch finnischen krieges
1939 40 als die sowjetunion damals eine
überlegene macht finnland angriff
natürlich verlor finnland territorium
aber es bekam eine neue politische
identität und oder zu dem was es heute
ist
ja das war der wintergrippe
und dann gibt es noch das vierte
szenario das wohl leider das
wahrscheinlichste ist das könnte man
korea szenario nennen nämlich kein
frieden das land wurde geteilt werden
man weiß nicht auf welche weise es gibt
keinen friedensvertrag
das wäre ganz einfach ein eingefrorener
konflikt der für lange zeit bleiben
würde aber dieses szenario ist höchst
problematisch sowohl für russland als
auch für die ukraine sage ihnen was es
für beide seiten bedeutet für russland
würde eine situation ohne
friedensvertrag heißen dass die
sanktionen sowohl europas als auch
amerikas weiterbestehen wenn es kein
friedensabkommen gibt und putin an der
macht bleibt sehe ich nicht dass zb der
amerikanische kongress die sanktionen
aufheben würde
was bedeutet ein solches szenario für
die ukraine
stellen sie sich vor der konflikt geht
drei vier oder fünf jahre ohne
friedensvertrag weiter
56 millionen menschen sind außerhalb des
landes die meisten sind frauen und
kinder
diese kinder werden zur schule gehen und
es wird sehr schwierig sein sie aus
deutschland oder bulgarien wieder in die
ukraine zu bringen
auch immer mehr männer werden ihren
frauen ins ausland folgen das land
entvölkert sich langsam dieser
demografische aspekt des ukraine krieges
wird noch gar nicht diskutiert
ich habe genau zugehört was putin in den
letzten sechs monaten gesagt hat dreimal
kam er ungefragt mit demselben satz
hätte es die revolution nicht gegeben
und den zweiten weltkrieg auch nicht und
wäre die sowjetunion nicht
auseinandergefallen dann gäbe es heute
500 millionen russen in der welt
offensichtlich war das eine
demografische rechnung die auf den
berühmten russischen gelehrten mendel ef
zurückgeht putin hat angst vor einer
schrumpfenden bevölkerung in russland
die geburtenraten im land sind niedrig
durch ko wittert russland eine million
menschen verloren und nach seiner
meinung ist es die einzige möglichkeit
demografisch wieder aufzuholen wenn man
die ukraine zu russen macht
sie wollen sagen putin braucht nicht das
land aber auch die leute